Amazon anunciaba una nueva Ronda de
despidos masivos a empleados así lo dio
a conocer mediante un comunicado Andy
yasi director general de la compañía
Durante las próximas semanas nueve mil
trabajadores se verán afectados
sumándose a los despidos que comenzaron
en noviembre del año pasado y que se
extendieron hasta enero dejando sin
empleo a un total de 27.000 personas
durante varios años previos a este la
mayoría de nuestros negocios agregaron
una cantidad significativa de empleados
sin embargo dada la incertidumbre
económica en la que vivimos y la
incertidumbre que existe en el futuro
cercano hemos optado por ser más
eficientes en nuestros costos y personal
ya así aseguró que las áreas que se
verán más afectadas serán los servicios
web el reclutamiento humano publicidad y
la aplicación de streaming tweets la
cual no ha dado los resultados esperados
a la compañía Igualmente aseguró que
durante la pandemia se crearon nuevos
empleos que ahora ya no son necesarios
Porque el repunte de la demanda cayó a
medida que se relajaron las
restricciones Por lo cual también se
produce el Amazon es la segunda empresa
con mayor número de empleados de Estados
Unidos con 1.5 millones de trabajadores
solamente por detrás de los
supermercados Walmart así el gigante del
comercio electrónico se suma a otras
empresas tecnológicas como Microsoft y
meta la matriz de Facebook la cual dijo
que eliminaría 10.000 empleos este año
luego de acabar con 11.000 puestos en
total el sector tecnológico ha despedido
a más de 200.000 personas Amazon ha
dicho que sus ganancias operativas
Pueden seguir cayendo en los próximos
meses debido a las condiciones
económicas a nivel global mientras que
sus acciones cayeron un 1.4% luego del
anuncio